thank you very much and yes also thank
you very much for spelling out our our
title that might sound a little vague
but I'm extremely happy to have you all
here and to talk to you about Onyx a
technology that I am personally very
excited about I'm pretty sure Kuba is as
well and we are quanco are also
extremely excited about it it really has
become a bit of a Cornerstone technology
actually at Quanto over the last 12
months some people might recognize we
actually also had a talk last year at
Quan at the pi data here that one a year
ago was more high level generally
introducing the technology this talk
today really we want to drive home the
point that it is production ready we are
actually using it in production in large
scale uh projects and we're extremely
happy and as I said extremely excited to
talk about it so
how are we going to go
about spreading this kind of excitement
so the first step we are just going to
walk through the standard life cycle of
a machine learning project that many of
you might be familiar with and then from
there we will see that
in the beginning it's all great but then
later when you especially when you come
towards the deployment side actually you
probably might be running into problems
or you probably have some personal
experience running into problems and
that is really where this technology
Onyx comes into play and at that point
we then also will tell you why we think
that the library we've actually just
open sourced a few weeks ago called
spocks is really filling an important
void in this regard
um
yes so let's jump into the life cycle of
a machine learning project
so we are here at the python conference
so probably what you're going to do as
one of the very first steps you're going
to Define your very model you're going
to define a pipeline you're going to
Define your feature engineering you're
obviously going to do it and Python and
the world is great like we want to have
this rapid
development life cycle we want to
visualize some data we want to use
pandas we just really python is
extremely hard to beat in this early
phase of of a project
um and yeah we while we Define our model
we really write it into source code and
within the source code essentially lives
in our training environment so we have
other dependencies we might for example
have light GBM Etc so that is sort of
the dotted line uh here this is like a
environment with like further
dependencies now of course we are not
happy just defining a machine learning
model as source code of course what we
really want to do is we want to train it
we want to train it on our training data
so the next step is well training so we
take our data we call fit or whatever
our framework sort of provides and then
we end up with our trained model in our
process in our python process memory so
now it's a very very complex object that
just resides in the memory and then
of course we usually or we probably
never want to deploy directly from our
training process like the training and
the inference or the deployment is
pretty much always like a separate step
so we somehow need to now put this into
an into some kind of artifact that we
can then sort of ship around if you look
at the cycle learn documentation online
for example you will see that well what
they are actually doing uh or what is
sort of the official recommendation as
well called pickle it's built in and
then you get like a pickle file
honestly I think it's to some extent
extremely amazing that you can do this
with python in the first place that you
can just dump a model generically but I
put a question mark here because well
while it's actually
kind of amazing it does come with a lot
of problems uh as we will discuss in the
next slide uh namely
um
yeah what pickle does it like it only
dumps the state does not dump the logic
so if we actually then want to load the
pickle file and then run the inference
with our model we have to provide we
have to maintain this entire training
environment we have to recreate it on
our inference side so one way of doing
this of course is we could just
wrap this in a Docker image and
essentially bake it but again this also
comes with some issues now this does
take me then to the next and well
potentially last step of the development
life cycle namely okay we want to deploy
it I just mentioned it we probably a
common approach would be to pack it into
a Docker container or something but what
kind of issues maybe then sort of uh
encounter doing deployment and this is
then also a bit of the solution we want
to present so
I believe at the point already quite a
bit pickle pickle comes with problems so
now we have wrapped everything uh we
have we need to recreate the training
environment pretty much exactly in the
way uh we had it during training at the
inference part and now instead of just
saying like oh here's one file just run
this and uh you're good and for your
diploma you know I have to say like oh
here's an entire container it is very
difficult to distribute just because
it's like a file plus an entire
environment a pickle file plus the
entire environment now
more or less a corollary of of these
pickle issues is it's not only difficult
to just to distribute your model it's
also difficult to Archive so for example
with Quantico we often have the problem
uh or not a problem but like it's it's a
requirement that our models need to
remain online for like a long period of
time so order of magnitudes like several
years and now if we sort of just really
bake all the dependencies from our
training time into our container this
can create a lot of security issues for
example if you can't update dependencies
it is also a problem if we want to
compose our model so for example we have
two models trained at different times
now we want to compose them in like one
python process that's pretty difficult
if the two pickle files have different
dependencies we just can't do it and
then same again we sort of if we want to
keep our intellectual property that was
used for training out of the deployment
again if we do it with pickle we're out
of luck because we have to pretty much
ship everything but even if we find
solutions for some of these problems all
of these problems that I'm going to show
here have individual solutions to be
fair even if we find problems to sort of
work around pickle we might actually
still run into like some more
fundamental issues like for example this
is actually what what really got us as
Quantico onto the Onyx track is
it might just be that running your
python model your cycle to learn model
is just too slow
so in our case we had like some very
strict latency requirements and our
model while not being like
per se super slow it was just
an order of magnitude at least too slow
and then switching to Onyx as I will
explain later we got several orders of
magnitude SS beta so yeah if if your
performance is too slow and you're you
started with the python 2 stack at that
point it might just be a bit
inconvenient
but
that might not actually be all so maybe
you could also see like in a scenario
where okay you've trained your model but
now you actually want to deploy it not
on like some server where you have
Docker maybe you want to
deploy it on on a mobile within a mobile
app or something and there of course you
can't really just run python easily so
you would need to like somehow export it
and all of these issues again have maybe
individual Solutions but
um
there's actually one one way that we can
really solve them elegantly all
altogether in order to figure that out
let's take a step back
why is this why is this so hard why do
we have this problem with machine
learning uh models how to distribute
them Etc while the rest of the software
engineering world seems to have figured
out how to distribute software decades
ago so let's take a look how everybody
else is doing it
for non-machine learning related
software we might have something like
this we start off with source code
let's say it's Java
and now we have a compilation step again
this is somewhat in a compilation
environment
there's probably like some very very
complex objects floating around during
the compilation process but then at the
end
at the end we really arrive with some
artifact that is
more or less or like pretty much
completely independent from the
environment used during compilation and
we can now vendor this artifact very
easy it's very easy to deploy
again this is in the non-machine
learning process
now let's contrast that with machine
learning
so I've shown part of this uh before we
we start with our source code that
defines our pipeline we have our data we
have a training step and then we end up
with this trained Model A Big Blob in
the python
um
uh process and now what we kind of want
to do is very simple we want to have a
magic step we want to have some way to
like compile this big object in our
python memory into some artifact that
now is outside of our training
environment not inside anymore so that
when we deploy it we just need to grab
this one binary file put it somewhere
it's actually
who here actually was at the web
assembly talk just before
ah very few Obama because technically
it's what web assembly would also solve
well okay but we really want to have
this one binary file that we get and
then
we deploy that so I'm pretty sure you
might have some questions about this
magic step uh but just to sort of say
okay why is this all worth the trouble I
actually before getting it to the magic
step and Kuba is actually going to
explain that in detail in a moment I
just want to say like okay what is it
that makes it so great to have the
artifact outside of the training
environment so let's say let's look up
what the deployment actually looks like
oh yeah sorry
so the solution to all of this is you
might have guessed it from uh already
being mentioned like several times this
artifact is a standard it's an open
source standard it's around since a few
years it's yeah it's called Onyx and
whenever in the following slide you see
something called model.onics that is
actually the artifact this is this
binary file this is the Holy Grail we
are actually attempting to get to yeah
all right so
what does the deployment look like let's
let's get that out of the way first bam
this is how easy deployment could be
like there is no Docker no nothing this
particular example is in Python but it
could be any other language we need a
runtime
where we load this artifact but it's our
only dependency this runtime in this
particular case it's completely written
in C plus plus it has bindings for
pretty much any language Under the Sun
including webassembly unfortunately not
a lot of people were in the talk
um and the way it works is essentially
you you grab this runtime
you create an inference session you just
point it to this file again this is the
only file you need to distribute there
is no other dependencies like there is
no you don't import your pipeline
anywhere and then when you want to do
inference on your model
you get your inputs as numpy arrays you
throw them at the session and this is
your outputs here that's it and in this
case it's python but again it could be
from C it could be from java it could be
from webassembly it could be anything
so this is really
really nice for deployment
now about this magical step
we have our trained model we have the
magic step and then we arrive at Onyx
how can this possibly work so the idea
behind this on extended and we don't
want to get too much into the details of
Onyx itself but the core idea really is
we have a set of standardized operators
just like numpy number has that numpy
sum numpy
mad mole and so on and we just have a
sequence of these operators where we
have like inputs and then the outputs
lead to the next set of operators and
eventually we arrive at the outputs we
like
yeah and then
um
pickle previously I mentioned it what
pickle does it only serializes the
weights of our giant models only the
state but the logic live somewhere else
now if we serialize something that is
defined in this standard with the Onyx
operators we serialize the logic needed
for the inference along with the state
and this is really the crucial
difference
all right
now let's get a little
before we get hand on let's actually
take a step back let's see what actually
is around in the Onyx ecosystem I
mentioned it before it's not completely
new there are quite a few projects
around it and let's take a step back to
see
where we are at
cool and Cuba is going to do that uh so
let's look around the whole all next
ecosystem and so what do we have what
are we dealing with so as Christian has
shown so if you know the image you have
right now of Onyx says well I got Onyx
film somewhere maybe it's this
primordial being it's just here already
and we can use it in run times so for
instance you have different runtimes for
instance there's the main line Onyx
runtime which is very quite widely
supported you have other runtimes you
may want to use if you target a
different platform like tracked for
embedded devices and so now let's think
about where does onyx actually come from
so in the scope of this we are sort of
looking at different machine learning
Frameworks we're getting models in those
machine machine learning Frameworks that
we trained and now somehow we have to
get them into Onyx so this process is
called conversion so the way it's done
is that we Implement converter libraries
and those conversation libraries take
care of taking a model object in in
Python and converting it into Onyx so
the way this is done currently in those
like quite big libraries which have
already accumulated good coverage of
Onyx converters basically is that
essentially every one of them has its
own way of doing it and that's not great
because writing Onyx you know from the
ground up it's not quite easy because
it's like quite a low level IR so it's a
quite a lower level language in a way
so what we've done in this space is we
introduced spocks and spocks is this new
way of writing all next yourself is that
you and as you will see it's actually
quite composable it leaves you with a
lot of headaches that you would get if
you're writing this yourself and with
spocks you can create your own
converters from your own Frameworks your
own libraries or just libraries that do
not have converters yet and you can
Implement that conversion into onyx
all right then so let's look into
expressing some models with spocks so in
sports well we're going to be converting
different pipeline components of
different like smaller model pieces
essentially so let's think about sort of
an SQL and oriented example since that's
quite close to home for us and for
instance we have a linear regression
sort of cycle learn like so there's some
initialization code private things we
don't really care about there's a fit
method that we assume will have already
been called when we get to the
conversion steps or there's some fet and
what we really care about is sort of how
does predict look how does the inference
logic look so here you know we're
consuming an array for this in an array
and there's some matrix multiplication
with our coefficients as fit and we add
an intercept value so we can see that
there's some trained weights those are
the attributes essentially of this model
and there's some simple numpy operations
we're doing on that
so that's a simple view on the uh that's
sort of going to drive our example so
now let's look into how we can structure
a spox converter
so this code here is really just a bit
of boiler applied to sort of say what
we're doing so a converter is sort of
this class for us where we created a
converter for a given pipeline component
so we could here we call it a model so
the linear regression is this sort of
component this model and we give the
converter access to it because we are
still in Python we want to be able to
access all that same stay all those
attributes now the nice thing we're
going to do is actually replicate the
same sort of interface the linear
regression object has uh with the
converter object with the Spock sort of
version of it so this predict method is
going to take this VAR object which I'm
going to explain in a second and we
change some new VAR so now what is VAR
in spocks we sort of abstract away the
fact that because we're describing sort
of the inference logic there's no
concrete runtime value there's no array
to speak of so instead bar represents
this variable this lazy value that will
access our runtime here we're just sort
of thinking about it abstractly that we
are going to be applying to operations
to it getting some results out and all
those visas are going to be variables so
in this specific case we're going to say
the variable is an array it's just a
lazy array it doesn't have concrete
values
uh oh all right then so let's look at
how the prediction logic looks so this
is it it's quite explicit but it's
actually quite simple to uh sort of
dissect so first of all does this op
I've introduced here so spoke surf
exposes for you these Onyx operators
those standardized operators on the
Krishna was talking about and those are
exposed in the op module they are quite
similar to numpy there's a lot of them
they're domain specific ones for deep
learning but or computer vision but also
like quite basic ones like arithmetic
here so that's the first thing to notice
so we have an additional and a matrix
multiplication happening and we also
have these const calls so what's
happening is that we're accessing
self.model so our converted model and
the state of that model as trained so
those training weights and we are this
const call this constant operator is
explicitly taking those weights and
moving them into a Onyx model
essentially we are saying this is part
of the model we're moving it into like a
variable
and this way we essentially Express the
entire logic that's made with
reciprocation with the coefficients an
addition of an interested value and this
same exact idea applies to a lot of
different converters you can have so
pre-processing components like scalars
or different ways of input infusing data
and so on this sort of same concept
applies
so moving on if we sort of have this
those Basics this actually applies the
same level idea in Spock's applies to
well more high level things so for
instance let's think Okay so we've
defined these converters now I want to
have an arbitrary model and just ask for
a fox converter for it so I'm going to
write this function called converter
it's going to check okay what kind of
model is this I'm going to return the
upper up here uh dispatcher appropriate
converter so say I've got this now so
for instance a quite useful SK learn uh
concept is pipelines so in pipelines
we're going to Define that converter for
a pipeline and what a pipeline does this
is going to be essentially this what
you're looking at it's essentially the
same implementation as in cycle learn so
a pipeline is defined it has a bunch of
steps in it it takes the data at the
start and it applies all the steps in
the pipeline consecutively transforms
the data as given and then for the last
step it says oh that's an estimator I'm
going to take this pre-process data give
it to that estimator so I'm calling
predicts there and I get my result out
the result of this Pipeline and yeah and
that's basically that
so here the really the only difference
the only spokes thing that's happening
is if you look here I place this
converter call so step itself is a
python object representing a model so
it's like you learn like but converters
are you know dispatching the right
converter for it so we are getting the
spokes version and because we follow the
same interface
of the cycle learn does with spocks so
we have a transfer method we have a
predict method which called takes a
single value we get what we want
essentially we just apply all those
steps consecutively but we apply the
Onyx versions of them
and that's quite cool since this is
quite a extensible approach of doing it
all right so let's sort of now think
okay but I'm sort of talking about these
variables and like well we got these
magical objects we're applying operators
operations to them where did they come
from and like I mean for this let's
start thinking about first like how do
we get to this point where we actually
can't convert a model uh well to do this
first we are actually you know training
the model we are so we take I defined
here a very simple pipeline quite
trivial we have a scalo we have our
aggression and I'm fitting that Pipeline
with some training data essentially and
that's that's done
now you know I can be anywhere else in
the python you know uh process and at
this point I'm gonna start thinking
about how am I doing to do my Onyx
conversion so I'm going to get some
spots imported so these are a few
utilities are going to be useful and I'm
going to access my converter library
that implemented using Sports so this is
just represented in this converter
function as defined on the previous
slide so VAR was this placeholder for
data and Onyx is actually strongly typed
and statically typed as well so the way
we're going to say oh this is like a
variable this variable is going to
arrive at runtime we're going to
introduce something called an argument
an argument is just a placeholder for
data of a given type so say here I have
a tensor type which is just a fancy way
of saying array in this case and it's a
float64
array which is just a vector it has a
single Dimension some size n
and as I have this placeholder now this
x which is a variable I can give it to
the pipeline to the converter of the
pipeline here and I get my y out which
is the result of this pipeline this is
the result of my model this is what I
want to essentially compute from X
uh where X is sum of some input and the
way spocks allows you to wrap this up is
you say okay so my model Olympus I want
my argument essentially is this x I'm
going to call it X we have to say since
in the file in the in the mode will sort
of say oh these are the inputs you have
with these names and these are all tools
you get with these names and yeah in
build we say Okay X is my model input
why is my model output and model becomes
this special Onyx object representing
the computation representing the model
and at this point we've done
serialization all the dependencies are
gone model is just this essentially a
representation for a binary object and
we can just go on x.save we save it into
our file and it's done and how that's
being done look for Onyx it looks
something like this for the super basic
pipeline you can actually visualize it
as the sort of dag as the sort of graph
this Tasker graph in a way if you maybe
use dusk or maybe if you spy church or
tensorflow those are in a way layers but
these operators are much more primitive
so for instance you can see on the
around the sort of main path you see the
constants so those are the model weights
that we had so now they explicitly
serialized within the model file and we
have you know a different multiplication
those came from the scalar and matrix
multiplication addition those come from
the regression and so if we applied all
these operators all the dependencies
from python are stripped out and we are
left with just this computation itself
and with that we have the products and
let's summer and Christian will
summarize what we've got yes thank you
very much
all right so quick summary uh what are
we what do we think
why are we so excited about spocks why
are we so excited about Onyx so in
general
it's a tool Onyx is a tool to like
compile your trained machine learning
model into something self-continent and
it might not be obvious immediately but
it's an extremely extremely powerful
approach actually to solving a whole
host of issues now well those issues are
you get like very stable very very fast
and very maintainable deployment and uh
what we really really want to stress
with this talk this is production ready
it's not like oh some Fancy Pants uh
technology uh somewhere at the Horizon
this is actually here this can be used
and it has strong corporate backing
original Onyx is uh developed and pushed
by Microsoft but by now it's also Nvidia
IBM Etc behind it and it really has been
a key technology at Quantico for now
more than 12 months in production and
everything we've presented here is open
source so if you're interested and share
some of the excitement check out uh this
link for spocks where you find some more
documentation and tutorials Etc
thank you very much thank you very cool
[Applause]
thank you very much for your talk
um
I got one question which is almost the
same as two other questions on slider so
how do you deal with pre-processing
steps in Onyx models because it's an
important part of AI model to get the
data into a form how the model is
trained on so is there a solution on
onyx yes I'm actually very glad then if
that was unclear that the question came
because uh
you can well
I guess hear it well forever so the the
point really is
okay I don't find the slide now
um the point is uh
it's not only like the trio summer
regressor at the very end it's your
entire feature engineering pipeline
there are like about 180 standardized
operations in the Onyx standard where
it's just you get inputs something is
being done to them like for example you
encode you impute whatever you clip all
of these have standard operations in the
standard you can do your entire feature
engineering pipeline so in our
production use case we have models with
thousands of nodes
and it just works and yeah
so it's really end to end cool
and another question is
how to convert your own and if an
operator of a modal neural network is
not implemented in Awan and x and
unknown placeholders returned great
question we also have something for that
well this is about this one is a bit
more generic but there's several
mechanisms for the English this one of
them is essentially custom operators so
the standard is extensible there are
ways of saying okay I'm going to provide
this operator I'm going to call it this
and this and then various runtimes are
supposed to provide ways to essentially
link those implementations so all next
runtime allows you to link a dynamic
Library you can Implement your own
custom operators the new source of
dealing with that as well in terms of
expressibility you can actually Express
a law with all next because it actually
gives you full-blown control flow which
spokes allows you to use so you can
handle if you have like operators which
don't access which requires a simple
branching or even if they acquire like
complex looping then you can actually
Express a lot of things so for instance
there's a we had experiments first oh
there's no join implemented in nonix
well we can do a custom operator or we
can prototype station with a loop
essentially and we Implement like a
known algorithm and that's still more
efficient than pure python so yeah there
are ways of dealing with that cool thank
you very much the time is over there
there's still questions there on slider
and perhaps also in the room but I think
you are around here so uh just directly
talk to the speakers I think and again
Applause thank you very much thank you
very much